zusatzpunkt fünf interfraktionell wird
überweisung der vorlage auf drucksache
18 55 an die in der tagesordnung
aufgeführten ausschüsse vorgeschlagen
gibt es weitere überweisungs vorschläge
das ist nicht der fall dank erfahren wir
wie vorgeschlagen
tagesordnungspunkt 30 wir kommen nun zur
abstimmung über die beschlussempfehlung
des ausschusses für klimaschutz und
energie zu dem entschließungsantrag der
fraktionen der cdu/csu zu der abgabe
einer regierungserklärung durch den
bundesminister für wirtschaft und
klimaschutz zu dem thema für eine sozial
ökologische marktwirtschaft
transformation innovativ gestalten
jahreswirtschaftsbericht
2022 der ausschuss empfiehlt in seiner
beschlussempfehlung auf drucksache 18 35
den entschließungsantrag der fraktionen
der cdu/csu auf drucksache
524 abzulehnen auf verlangen der
fraktion der cdu/csu stimmen wir über
die beschlussempfehlung
namentlich ab es liegt eine erklärung
zur abstimmung nach § 31 unserer
geschäftsordnung vor die abstimmung
erfolgt in der westen obi sie haben zur
abgabe ihrer stimme 20 minuten zeit die
schriftführerin und schriftführer sind
bereits an ihren plätzen dann eröffnet
so also die abstimmung hier wird
eröffnet in diesem antrag fordert die
union unter anderem dass eben dieser
förderstopp der ja auch diskutiert würde
wieder sofort rückgängig gemacht wird
und die abgeordneten wenn jetzt also in
der west lobby das ist außerhalb des
plenarsaals hier abstimmen dieses
verfahren hat sich in der pandemie hier
eingebürgert um abstand halten zu können
wäre wenn man abstimmen der nächste
tagesordnungspunkt
beschäftigt sich mit an
bundeswehreinsatz schon seit
1978 überwachen un-blauhelmsoldaten das
grenzgebiet zwischen dem libanon und
israel das war eigentlich als
übergangslösung geplant aber diesen
einsatz uni viel gibt es immer noch dass
es kurz für united nations interim force
in lebanon und die bundeswehr beteiligt
sich mit bis zu 300 soldaten laut mandat
auch an diesem einsatz und die
bundesregierung möchte diesen einsatz
nun um ein weiteres jahr verlängern
und da wir eine parlamentsarmee haben
muster der bundestag dafür zu stimmen
allerdings wird er das noch nicht heute
machen heute ist hier die erste debatte
zu diesem antrag der bundesregierung auf
fortsetzung der beteiligung 40 minuten
sind geplant danach wird dieser antrag
den federführenden auswärtigen ausschuss
überwiesen und als erste rednerin wird
christine lambrecht
bundesverteidigungsminister für diese
fortsetzung werden
die bürgerinnen und bürger des libanon
am vergangenen sonntag ein neues
parlament gewählt und dabei kam es zu
stromausfällen dabei kam es zu
gewaltsamen zwischenfällen und diese
ereignisse sind sinnbildlich für die
tiefe krise in der sich dieses land
befindet die wirtschaft und die finanzen
des landes liegen am boden die
auswirkungen treffen die krisengeplagte
libanesischen bevölkerung hat es fehlt
an lebensmitteln
medikamenten infrastruktur es gibt immer
wieder stromausfälle und kaum arbeit
verschärft wird die lage durch die
vielen menschen die aus dem benachbarten
syrien in den libanon berlin auf eine
gesamtbevölkerung von circa sechs
millionen kommen geschätzte 1,5
millionen geflüchtete das hat enorme
humanitäre und auch
sicherheitspolitische folgen hinzu kommt
die korona pandemie und die verheerende
explosion im hafen von beirut vor knapp
zwei jahren die hoffnung und zuversicht
in die ministerin einen moment bitte
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen wir reden
hier über einen einsatz unserer
streitkräfte und ich bitte um eine
gewisse aufmerksamkeit zumindest hier
vorne kommt wirklich eine unglaubliche
lautstärke an es ist ganz schwer dagegen
anzureden vielen dank
vielen dank für die unterstützung nicht
versucht es dennoch dagegen anzurennen
reden denn ich glaube dieses thema ist
es tatsächlich wert dass man zuhört dass
man dann auch sich die entsprechenden
gedanken macht um seine entscheidung
treffen zu können wie man mit diesem
mandat umgehend
hoffnung und zuversicht in weiten teilen
der bevölkerung der libanesischen
bevölkerung schwinden und deswegen ist
es umso wichtiger dass diese uni viel
mission der vereinten nationen
fortgeführt werden kann es geht nämlich
darum dass diese gemengen lade dich
beschrieben habe nicht erneut zum
pulverfass wird der einsatz gesichert
das ende eines gewalt reichen direkten
konfliktes zwischen israel und dem
libanon langfristig hilft eine erneute
eskalation zwischen den beiden ländern
zu vermeiden und diese 1 es ist der
einzige direkte
kommunikationskanal zwischen israel und
dem libanon und wie wichtig dieser kanal
ist das hat uns gerade das vergangene
jahr gezeigt dem die spannung und die
dazu genommen haben unifi trägt aber
auch ganz entscheidend dazu bei
staatliche strukturen im libanon zu
stärken allein schon die wahlen am
vergangenen sonntag sind ein positives
zeichen dass die entwicklung in die
richtige richtung geht dass wir mit
unifi etwas für die menschen vor ort
verändern können meine damen und herren
unsere soldatinnen und soldaten leisten
hierzu einen maßgeblichen beitrag und
dafür gebührt ihnen anerkennung und
respekt vielen dank
die bundeswehr ist ein substanzieller
baustein der uni film mission seit
beginn der maritimen operation stellt
deutschland schiffe und personal und
seit januar vor einem jahr führen wir
den uni viel flottenverband wir stellen
unsere korvette erfurt für den maritimen
einsatzverband und von uni viel bereit
und so tragen wir aktiv zur see und
luftraumüberwachung vor der
libanesischen küste bei und verhindern
den waffenschmuggel über see denn die us
dollar die das existenzrecht israels
leugnet diese terrororganisation darf in
dieser region nicht an waffen geraten
wir handeln wenn die sicherheit israel
und ist es auch weiter nötig denn die
libanesische marine ist noch lange nicht
in der lage gesehen grenze des landes
eigenständig zu kontrollieren sie können
ihre küste überwachen und sehen was
passiert das ist möglich sie können aber
noch nicht selbstständig reagieren wenn
sie etwas auffälliges beobachtet genau
wie hier setzen wir an einerseits drang
unsere soldatinnen und soldaten selbst
dazu bei die seegrenzen zu sichern
andererseits stärken wir die
eigenständigkeit der libanesischen
marine durch material und ausbildung zb
versorgen wir den libanon mit
technischer ausrüstung für die
küstenüberwachung und unsere soldatinnen
und soldaten lernen die libanesischen
kameraden hier an
unser ziel bleibt der libanon soll seine
seegrenzen selbst schützen können und
zwar vollständig und dauerhaft und ich
bin stolz sagen zu können die ausbildung
durch unsere truppe durch die bundeswehr
verbessert die einsatzbereitschaft der
libanesischen marine
alle damen und herren unser engagement
ist auch hoch willkommen sowohl libanon
und auch gerade israel wünschen sich
dass die vereinten nationen weiter
präsent bleiben und dass deutschland
sich weiter an ohne viel beteiligt
deshalb bitte ich sie dieses mandat zu
verlängern bildern
soweit
bundesverteidigungsministerium christine
lambrecht mittlerweile hat auch das
podium gewechselt bundestags
vizepräsidentin petra pau leitet jetzt
die sitzung das wort hat der kollege
thomas überholen für die
cdu/csu-fraktion und thomas silberhorn
war 2018 bis 2021 parlamentarische
staatssekretär bei der bundesministerin
der verteidigung
seit 2009 10 die größte wirtschafts und
finanzkrise in der geschichte des landes
und das zeitig massive spuren die
inflation liegt bei über 200 prozent das
libanesische pfund hat mehr als 90
prozent seines wertes verloren drei
viertel aller menschen im libanon leben
nach angaben der vereinten nationen an
der armutsgrenze viele können schlicht
ihre familien nicht mehr ernähren und
der massive verlust an kaufkraft
beeinträchtigt auch die versorgung der
libanesischen sicherheitskräfte
dazu kommen die schon angesprochenen 1 5
millionen flüchtlinge aus syrien die
noch immer im land sind und die für
sechs millionen einwohnern ist lieber
nur noch immer die höchste
flüchtlingsboote weltweit sind wenn wir
heute meine damen und herren
eine verlängerung des unifil mandats auf
den weg bringen dann müssen wir schon
auch klar benennen wer für die
verelendung weiter bevölkerungskreise in
libanon die verantwortung trägt es ist
eine politische klasse die
offenbar in einer anderen realität lebt
als die eigene bevölkerung für die sie
sagen sollte und deswegen ist es schon
an normalen das dringend nötige reformen
endlich auf den weg gebracht werden
woran es seit monaten und jahren mangelt
die politischen kräfte blockieren sich
gegenseitig und reißen ihr eigenes land
in den abgrund die wahlen am vergangenen
wochenende haben offen gelegt wie wenig
das libanesische volk seinen regierenden
vertraut 41 prozent haben sich an den
wahlen beteiligt
59 prozent nicht das ist ein glattes
misstrauensvotum der bevölkerung gegen
die eigenen politisch verantwortlichen
das proporzsystem in regierung und
parlament lässt dennoch tief greifende
veränderungen wohl kaum erwarten aber
das wahlergebnis
insbesondere der unerwartet große
dämpfer für die hizbullah sollte doch
anlass zum umdenken sein die
entscheidungsträger ebern und müssen
ihre eigenen verantwortung nachkommen
meine damen und herren
die libanesischen streitkräfte sind in
allen teilen der bevölkerung anerkannt
sie leisten einen unverzichtbaren dienst
um frieden und stabilität im libanon zu
bewahren denn sie sind auch im ganzen
land im einsatz was wir in deutschland
und europa oft wenig wahrnehmen mit der
unterstützung der libanesischen armee
und mit der präsenz im land tragen die
vereinten nationen deshalb erheblich zur
stabilität des libanon bei die
beteiligung der bundeswehr an der
maritimen komponente von uni viel hat
sich bewährt unsere soldaten und
soldatinnen
leisten ebenfalls einen wertvollen
beitrag zur stabilität des libanon der
sowohl vom libanon als auch von israel
ausdrücklich anerkannt wird und deswegen
haben die angehörigen der bundeswehr die
im libanon und allem was dazugehört
einschließlich limassol in zypern unser
aller dank und unsere wertschätzung für
ihren einsatz verdient meine daten
das im rahmen des neuen mandat ist eine
korvette zu amerika task force zu
erklären soll macht durchaus sinn
zielsetzung unseres engagements ist
allerdings immer dass wir die
libanesischen streitkräfte so ausbilden
so unterstützen so beraten dass sie die
verantwortung für ihre sicherheit
schrittweise in den eigenen händen
halten können und vor dem hintergrund
es ist durchaus hilfreich wenn wir mit
partnern der vereinten nationen
gelegentlich rotieren wir waren mit
einer palette schon drin und sind raus
jetzt gehen wir wieder rein das macht
durchaus sinn aber zur
verantwortungsübergabe in libanesische
hände gehört eben auch dass neben aus
bildungs und beratungsleistungen die
materiellen voraussetzungen dafür
geschaffen werden weder wir noch unsere
partner in den vereinten nationen haben
dazu signifikante beiträge
leisten können dafür gibt es gründe es
gibt auch eine hohe eigenverantwortung
der libanesischen streitkräfte ihre
marine entsprechend auszustatten aber es
ist gut dass wir im rahmen dieses uni
viel man das auf die ertüchtigung
initiative der bundesregierung hinweisen
die bereits eingesetzt wird für die
materielle ausstattung der libanesischen
streitkräfte und an dieser stelle kann
man in der tat mehr tun die
radarüberwachung der küste die wir mit
geschaffen und für die wir ausgebildet
haben ist dafür ein gutes beispiel
vielen dank für ihre aufmerksamkeit
thomas in silber hund war das ist
übrigens auch mitglied in der
parlamentarischen versammlung der nato
das sind parlamentarier sie von den 30
nato-staaten über sicherheits- und
verteidigungspolitische themen beratung
und bundestagsvizepräsidentin petra pau
erinnert sich nochmal an die abstimmung
[Musik]
das wort hat der staatsminister dr
wir als länder als staatsminister im
auswärtigen amt
vielen dank frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen kollegen meine sehr geehrten
damen und herren es ist das interesse
der bundesregierung
eine weitere die stabilisierung libanons
und eine zuspitzung der humanitären lage
zu verhindern
dies hätte weitreichende
sondern eben auch internationale folgen
die parlamentswahlen die am vergangenen
sonntag stattgefunden haben sie zeichnen
ein gemischtes bild die wählerinnen und
wähler haben deutlich gemacht dass sie
mit der bisherigen regierung nicht
zufrieden sind die koalition um die
hisbollah hat ihre parlamentsmehrheit
verloren neue unabhängige und
reformorientierte abgeordnete ziehen ins
parlament ein und gleichzeitig meine
damen und herren droht die gefahr
politischer blockaden und einer langen
phase der regierungsbildung
in der dringend benötigte reformen
weiter ausbleiben und gerade deshalb ist
es jetzt wichtig dass wir unser breites
engagement zur unterstützung des libanon
aufrechterhalten die bundesregierung
verfolgt dabei einen umfassenden ansatz
der verschiedene außenpolitische
sicherheits und entwicklungspolitische
instrumente und maßnahmen im bereich zur
stabilisierung und menschenrechte im
libanon kombiniert und zu engagement für
land in region berücksichtigt dabei
sowohl
libanesische als auch israelische
interessen meine damen und herren es ist
klar
damit sich die desolate lage des libanon
nachhaltig verbessert muss das land ganz
tochter reformen umsetzen das erfordert
einen langen atem und von der
internationalen gemeinschaft einen
konsequenten und dauerhaften einsatz die
unterstützung der libanesischen
streitkräfte durch die friedensmission
uni viel ist dabei ein zentraler faktor
und lassen sie mich kurz zur lage der
libanesischen streitkräfte ausführen sie
sind einer der wenigen faktoren die den
libanon
konfessionsübergreifend 1 aber leider
befinden auch sie sich in einer
zunehmend prekären lage der haushalt der
libanesischen armee leidet unter dem
gravierenden kaufkraftverlust des
libanesischen pfunds und dies hat
erhebliche auswirkungen auf die
einsatzfähigkeit der streitkräfte
deutschland hat seine neue ausstellung
der mission uni fiel nach dem krieg
zwischen libanon und israel im jahr 2006
viel zu dieser mission beigetragen
die langjährige deutsche unterstützung
für die streitkräfte wird im libanon
wahrgenommen
deutschland wird als wichtiger partner
geschätzt die maritime komponente ist
ein zentraler pfeiler von uni vieles
kernaufgabe den waffenstillstand zu
gewährleisten und kernstück unseres
deutschen beitrags zur stabilisierung
und ertüchtigung sind die beteiligung am
uni flottenverband versicherung des
vielseitigen grenzen und eben auch der
fähigkeit aufbau der libanesischen
marine
denn erst wenn die libanesische marine
dauerhaft fähigkeiten entwickelt hat
kann sie ihre küstengewässer
eigenständig überwachen erst dann kann
der maritime flottenverband der mission
zurückgefahren werden und wie viel
arbeit mit unserer unterstützung
daraufhin aber wir sind noch lange nicht
am ziel meine sehr geehrten damen und
herren liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
die mission hat jemand da in einem sehr
volatilen regionalen umfang bisher gut
erfüllt und stabilisierend gewirkt nicht
zuletzt durch drei parteien gesprächen
mit israel und libanon und zweifelsohne
bleiben herausforderungen südlibanon
entlang der demarkationslinie
kommt es immer wieder zu verletzungen
des waffenstillstandes eine besondere
gefahr jetzt angesprochen worden die
dabei von nicht etliche gruppen vor
allem von der hisbollah aus die
libanesischen streitkräfte können dort
für uni fiel bislang nicht durchgehend
den uneingeschränkten zugang
gewährleisten mit unseren beitrag zu uni
vielleicht mir nicht zuletzt einen
wichtigen beitrag zum deutschen phono
mit vergleichsweise
überschaubar mitteleinsatz verbessern
wir in einer klar definierten
erfolgreicher mission die angespannte
lage im einsatzgebiet maßgeblich und
sind verlässlicher partner nahm der
bundesregierung bitte ich sie deshalb um
ihre zustimmung zur verlängerung dieses
mandat vielen dank
tobias lindner war das nicht hier auch
kurz für die fortführung geworben dass
die abstimmung zu wohnen zur
namentlichen abstimmung in drei minuten
geschlossen werden wer noch nicht
gelegenheit hatte an der abstimmung
teilzunehmen möge dies jetzt tun wir
fahren jetzt zurück und der nächste
redner steht schon bereit joachim
wundrak auf die fraktion und mitglied im
auswärtigen ausschuss
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin werte kollegen zu meine
damen und herren
lassen sie mich zu beginn
unmissverständlich betonen dass wir
anders als andere parteien dieses hauses
das existenzrecht israels
ohne wenn und aber anerkennen
als das verteidigungsministerium im jahr
2006 mit der frage der beteiligung an
der maritimen komponente von unifi
befasst wurde gab es bedenken dass eine
mögliche konfrontation mit israelischen
kräften vor der küste libanons zu
politischen verwerfungen führen könnte
die deutsche marine übernahmen im
september 2006 die führung dieser welt
ein task force mit einem eigenen großen
verband mit bis zu sechs schiffen und
circa 700 soldaten und tatsächlich gab
es bald einige zwischenfälle durch tiefe
überflüge israelischer kampfflugzeuge
über deutsche schiffe dies konnte
allerdings schnell und professionell
durch die militärische führung und auch
durch ein gespräch auf ministerebene
bild beigelegt werden
allerdings gab es schon damals die
aussage der israelis dass die
anwesenheit der deutschen marine vor der
küste des libanon zwar willkommen sei
jedoch werde deren mission gegen den
waffenschmuggel
insbesondere waffenschmuggel zu gunsten
des dollar wohl unmöglich wirksam
bleiben werte belegen mittlerweile sind
16 jahre vergangen
derzeit werde es gehört wird wieder ein
deutscher admiral diese task force und
der deutsche beitrag soll auf ein schiff
und circa 60 soldaten reduziert werden
der nachweis der wirksamkeit der
maritimen mission von uni fiel gegen
waffenschmuggel kann weiterhin nicht
erbracht werden die verantwortung für
die überprüfungen der einlaufenden
handelsschiffe
liegt ausschließlich bei den
libanesischen behörden die ergebnisse
der überprüfung werden nicht mitgeteilt
allerdings und da haben das schon gehört
hat die deutsche marine in den
vergangenen jahren vor ort durchaus
hervorragendes geleistet
der aufbau einer küsten radar
organisationen einschließlich der
ausbildung war ein sehr erfolgreiches
projekt um die libanesischen behörden in
die lage zu versetzen selbst ihre küste
zu überwachen
ebenso ist die ausbildung der kleinen
libanesischen marine über die jahre so
erfolgreich verlaufen dass diese ihre
ausbildung nun auch selbst leisten kann
wie aber sieht es auf der deutschen
seite aus die deutsche marine des jahres
2022 ist nunmehr die kleinste marine die
deutschland je zur verfügung hatte
verantwortlich für diesen zustand sind
die parteien dieses hauses die in den
letzten 30 jahren
regierungsverantwortung in unserem land
getragen haben
der politische anspruch weil weltweit
mehr verantwortung übernehmen zu wollen
und die materielle und personal
personelle wirklichkeit der deutschen
marine stehen im krassen widerspruch
zueinander
es ist also an der zeit den deutschen
beitrag zu mehr itan taskforce juni viel
zu beenden und sich wieder der
kernaufgabe deutscher streitkräfte der
landes- und bündnisverteidigung
zuzuwenden
diese aufgaben sind geografisch in
erster linie in der ostsee nordsee und
im nordatlantik zu sehen und
insbesondere die aktuelle entwicklung in
osteuropa bedarf nun der erhöhten
aufmerksamkeit auch unserer marine die
jüngsten entscheidungen finnlands und
schwedens ihre aufnahme in die nato zu
beantragen haben zu offenen androhungen
von militärischen konsequenzen durch
russland geführt solange der artikel 5
des nato vertrages noch nicht für
finnland und schweden gilt sind
schutzmechanismen nur durch bilaterale
erklärungen zum beispiel von
großbritannien oder für uns zu treffen
durch den artikel 42 7 des eu vertrages
gegeben
dieser familie zustand kann aufgrund der
ablehnenden haltung der türkei zur nato
beitritt von finnland und schweden noch
einige zeit andauern also soll um die
einsätze der deutschen marine im
mittelmeer beendet werden um kapazitäten
für den kernauftrag der landes- und
bündnisverteidigung
freizusetzen die geplante korvette
vorbei und ist daher sinnvoller in der
ostsee einzusetzen danke für ihre auf
joachim wundrak die fraktion fordert
hier andere prioritäten zu setzen und
bundestagsvizepräsidentin wird jetzt die
abstimmung noch einmal auf rufen
beziehungsweise sie
wie schon erklärt die
bundestagsabgeordneten stimmung momentan
seit beginn der pandemie hier nicht im
plenarsaal ab das waren dann die bilder
die man sonst hier gesehen hat wo sich
doch alle abgeordneten sehr getummelt
haben in der mitte des plenarsaals
sondern das wird jetzt draußen
organisiert auf dem gang in der
sogenannten west lobby denn dort hat man
die möglichkeit das alles mit etwas mehr
abstand zu gestalten
und nächster redner ist frankfurter
rosentritt er sitzt für die fdp im
auswärtigen ausschuss
[Applaus]
ja sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen stellen sie
sich vor sie sitzen an einem gemütlichen
samstagmorgen mit der familie am
prächtig im bisherigen monat oder in der
partnerstadt meiner heimatstadt chemnitz
in kiriat bialik unweit der grenze zum
libanon und plötzlich explodiert eine
bombe in unmittelbarer nähe ihres hauses
oder ihrer wohnung mit glück haben
kommen mit dem schrecken davon wenn
nicht verlieren menschen die sie lieben
oder vielleicht sogar sich selbst ihr
leben ihre gesundheit oder ihren bis
jetzt man damit haben leider ist dies
alltag in der einzigen demokratie im
nahen osten die riffs ball klar hinter
angesprochen hat eine information von
militärexperten bis zu 150000 raketen
und über 50.000 kämpfer und nicht
unerheblich anteile davon im süden des
libanon stationiert und terrorisiert wo
immer es geht die menschen in israel
aber leider auch die eigene bevölkerung
im libanon der anlage und das habe ich
heute oft gehört aktuell katastrophal
ist allein im vergangenen jahr sind auf
israel von seiten des libanons am 13 mai
drei raketen am 17.6 am 19 04 am 20 juli
2 am 14 august zwei raketen abgeschossen
worden der jüngste beschluss war es in
diesem jahr am 25 april dieses jahres
vor wenigen wochen hatte ich die
gelegenheit mehr der grenze zum libanon
dass die persönlich die von der edf
entdeckten terror tunnel der hisbollah
anzuschauen welche die hisbollah unter
der libanesisch-israelischen grenze
getroffen hat um die tödlichen waffen
gegen menschen die die wir alle in
freiheit und demokratie leben
einzusetzen ich glaube niemand von uns
hier im haus und auch nicht oben auf der
tribüne will eines wir erleben wie
mitten beim kindergeburtstag beim fehler
bei spielte camp der kinder auf einmal
ein kämpfer aus dem terror tunnel die
wiese empor kommt man damit herren
diesen terror müssen wir beenden doch
die disco la
doch diesmal welche überwiegend von
piran finanziert wird es gibt nicht nur
eine bedrohung für israel sondern
genauso auch eine bedrohung für die
libanesische bevölkerung deren lage
wirklich katastrophal ist wir erinnern
uns noch alle an die gewaltige explosion
und brutale zerstörung im hafen da die
walisischen hauptstadt beirut am vierten
august 2020 bei der
2800 tonnen am mund umgedreht in einem
geheimen koalitionslager der hisbollah
explodierten 200 unschuldige menschen
starben dabei und zirka 300.000
libanesische menschen wurden obdachlos
denn es ist eine perversion nicht zu
übertreffen dass die hisbollah solche
munitionslager ähnlich wie die
palästinensische hamas in wohngebieten
einsetzt und und damit die bewohner als
lebendige schutzschilde für ihren terror
missbraucht man muss zudem langjährige
hisbollah chef hassan nasrallah zu hören
der ganz offen sagte
der sun ist ntt ist die temporary
anthony klein es bedeutet des tiroler
als box sieht dass irans nur ein
einziges ziel hat die vernichtung des
staates israel damen und herren für ein
land wie deutschland in dem
menschenrechte groß geschrieben werden
und dessen staatsverschuldung die
existenz und sicherheit israels ist für
so ein land ist das verhalten völlig
inakzeptabel und damit helfen
deshalb braucht deshalb braucht die
region das mandat uni vielen da stimme
ich meinem vorredner feigen dem
staatsminister lindner uneingeschränkt
zu mehr denn je eher die aufgabe dann
ungefähr sind eben auch die ermittlung
und die eliminierung solche terror
tunnel aus diesem grund werden wir als
freie demokraten für die verlängerung
stimmen und die vielen ist zweifelsohne
alle daten des un missionen und das ist
auch schon mehrfach gesagt wird ein ganz
beständig ist vermittler instrument
züchter israelischen und libanesischen
seite die fortsetzung der beteiligung
bewaffneter deutscher streitkräfte an
uni viel ist vor diesem hintergrund ein
enorm wichtiger beitrag um die
bedrohungslage für israel und aber auch
das line-up bevölkerung im libanon zu
mindern und für stabilität im süden des
libanons zu sorgen mein dank geht an
dieser stelle ganz besonderes dem 14
meral brücke und allen soldatinnen und
soldaten sowie den zahlreichen zivilen
einsätzen vor ort
die explosion in einer zeit gefreut dass
zusammenarbeit nicht ausschließe nicht
reibungslos verlief ministerin hat es
gesagt deshalb kommt der neuen regierung
im libanon eine ganz gewichtige rolle zu
welche uni fehlen eingeschränkten zugang
zu allen bereichen im süden des libanons
ermöglichen muss der uni viel hilft eben
auch nicht nur waffenschmuggel zu
verhindern sondern ist auch ein
unglaublich wichtiger um humanitäre
einsatz um transportwege zu sichern das
langfristige ziel im interesse der
menschen libanon unter menschen in
israel muss sein die terrororganisation
hisbollah im südlichen libanon seinen
waffen und die libanesische armee die
kontrolle wieder geben zu lassen damit
das südlibanon stabilisiert wird denn
wenn die sicherheit israels die starts
versorgung deutschland ist und
menschenrechte weltweit gelten dann ist
der einsatz ohne viel ein teil der
deutschen verantwortung das gehalt in
der vergangenheit und es gilt auch unter
zukunft deshalb freue ich möchte die
zustimmung zu diesen mandaten vielen
dank
frank müller rosentritt
folgt nun
gleich andrej hunko ich habe eben
gestoppt weil bundestags vizepräsidentin
petra pau eben jetzt erst die
namentliche abstimmung beendet hat und
gesagt hat nun sei aber wirklich die
zeit rum das heißt da gab es dann doch
noch einige
abgeordnete die in letzter minute zu den
oben
gerutscht sind
die kolleginnen hier im
vom bundestags dienst werden nun die
stimmen auszählen und das ergebnis
einreichen
andrej hunko spricht jetzt für den links
formationen euro präsidentin meine damen
und herren herr müller rosentritt sie
haben eben den libanon als die einzige
demokratie im nahen osten bezeichnet
dann hat sich vielleicht versprochen ich
will darauf hinweisen dass da habe ich
mich eher kann es ja nach schauen also
ich denke auch israel bei aller kritik
die man haben kann sollte man trotz
demokratie einstufen wir reden
heute über den einsatz
die verlängerung des einsatzes uni viel
an der küste libanons
es ist der dritte
militäreinsatz über den wir heute hier
debattieren im bundestag und es ist
seitdem
wir im bundestag überhaupt
über bewaffnete deutsche einsätze reden
und entscheiden
mittlerweile der 240 sste etwa der 240
der einsatz und der bundestag kann ja
nur zustimmen oder ablehnen da kann man
nichts ändern an den mandatstext und
frau
verteidigungsminister lambrecht wissen
sie wie häufig der bundestag ein mandat
abgelehnt hat kein einziges mal
das ist schon ein problem weil er ein
ritual entsteht dass man völlig
unabhängig von der lage die sich
entwickelt völlig unabhängig davon ob
die ziele die zu beginn formuliert
worden sind eingehalten werden ob die
eintreten oder nicht man stimmt immer zu
hier im bundestag und das sehen wir als
demokratieproblem in libanon das gilt
auch für diesen einsatz seit 16 jahren
und ich viel mit dem hauptzweck mit dem
hauptzweck
waffenlieferungen an den libanon an die
hisbollah dort vornehmlich zu
unterbinden und in diesen 16 jahren gab
es nicht einen einzigen
offiziell jedenfalls bestätigten
waffenfund dieser einsatz ist aus
unserer sicht ein sinnloser einsatz
in dem fall es ist kein riesen einsatz
es gibt viel viel größere einsätze hier
wird für diesen verringerung von einem
jahr sind 30 knapp 30 millionen euro
veranschlagt wir denken es wäre sehr
viel sinnvoller dieses geld dafür zu
investieren
dass die sich abzeichnende humanitäre
krise im libanon die jetzt vor allen
dingen auch dadurch entsteht dass die
weizen die lieferungen dass sie getreide
lieferung
reduziert wird dass die weizenpreise
steigen die wohnung ist da ein grosser
importeur in folge des krieges in der
ukraine und in folge auch der sanktionen
dass man sich darauf konzentriert diese
humanitäre krise abzuwenden und frau
verteidigungsministerin wenn sie sagen
naja aber der einsatz ist doch dafür gut
dass es in diplomatischen kanal gibt
zwischen israel und libanon ich glaube
auch dafür gibt es bessere instrumente
als einen deutschen militäreinsatz wir
werden diesen ansatz ableben vielen dank
ich erteile geben kollegen frank müller
rosentritt das wort für eine
kurzintervention
konnte und wollte jetzt nur ein mal klar
stellen also wenn man die ans rednerpult
geht in diesem hohen hause und bei dem
wort demokratie freiheit und pluralismus
nicht automatisch und israel denkt dann
ab bis man endlich die total
desorientiert oder allerdings partei
deshalb selbstverständlich meine ich mit
demokratie mit demokratie pluralismus
israel
wollen sie etwas erwidern dann haben sie
das wort
ja selbstverständlich deswegen hab ich
ja das erwähnt habe ich an israel gesagt
sie können ja nachschauen im protokoll
es war wahrscheinlich hat ein
versprecher ihrerseits aber ich denke
eben neben libanon sollte man im nahen
osten auch israels demokratie erwähnen
vielen dank
dann haben wir das geklärt und das wort
hat der kollege andreas lagen für die
spd
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte damen und herren liebe
kolleginnen kollegen lieber herr hunke
auch uns jetzt meine redezeit abgeht
aber ich habe gestern abend mit
vertretern hochrangigen vertretern der
ukraine gesprochen und wir haben aber
über die internationale welt und
sicherheits ordnung auch gesprochen und
wir haben eine veränderung in unserer
sicherheits ordnung ich komme in meiner
rede auch kurz drauf und deswegen ist es
nur gut klug und richtig dass wir uns an
diesen mandaten beteiligen und diese
drei mandate aufrechterhalten das wurde
auch noch mal in dem gespräch gestern
abend deutlich
alles hat seine zeit und nach dem
brutalen und verachtenswerten
angriffskrieg russlands auch die ukraine
wodurch sich nicht wo sich unser
weltweites sicherheits ordnung verändert
hat müssen wir uns jetzt den änderten
und veränderten außen und
sicherheitspolitischen herausforderungen
stellen und hierzu gehört auch ohne viel
und somit reden wir heute über den
libanon
er ist seit jahrzehnten ein konfliktherd
und schauplatz von kriegen und er ist
ein ort unendlichen leids der
libanesischen zivilbevölkerung wie auch
von eineinhalb millionen flüchtlingen es
ist eine tragödie
was aus diesem land geworden ist das
einst die grüne perle des orients war
das 1 1 modell des ausgleichs zwischen
religionen und bevölkerungsgruppen im
nahen osten
darstellte aktuell erlebt das kleine
mittelmeerland erneut schwere krisen
wirtschaftlich sozial und politisch die
währung verfällt das land wird mit aller
härte von getreide lieferausfällen aus
der ukraine betroffen es droht eine
katastrophe
hinzu kommt dass sie zurückliegenden
wahlen keinen wirklichen wahlsieger
hervorgebracht und erneut droht eine
nicht handlungsfähige regierung
auch wenn die aufgabe schwer lösbar
erscheint dürfen wir die menschen dort
dennoch nicht im stich lassen deshalb
ist es gut glück richtig und wichtig
dass diese bundesregierung sich für die
fortsetzung des uni viel mandates
ausspricht es kommt immer wieder entlang
der blauen linien der demarkationslinie
zu zwischenfällen die ungelösten fragen
in bezug auf die seegrenze zwischen
israel und libanon bergen nach wie vor
konfliktpotenzial deutschland ist
unverändert daran interessiert den
dauerhaften frieden und die stabilität
im nahen osten nachhaltig zu fördern
auch libanon und israel beide legen
großen wert auf die präsenz der
vereinten nationen und die deutsche
beteiligung an uni fielen somit bleibt
der beitrag der uni viel
friedensmission der vereinten nationen
für eine deeskalation von spannung und
zum erreichen dauerhafte stabilität im
libanon unerlässlich
deutschland engagiert sich derzeit mit
62 soldatinnen und soldaten
liebe kolleginnen kollegen an dieser
stelle hier und heute möchte ich die
gelegenheit nutzen um mich bei den
soldatinnen und soldaten zu bedanken die
einen großen und unerlässlichen beitrag
zum frieden in dieser krisen
erschütterten region leisten
worum geht es bei rooney film es geht um
die funktion von uni viel als
deeskalation und kommunikationskanal
durch diplomatie und vermittlung
spannung abzubauen ganz konkret vor ort
an der blauen linie und insbesondere in
den sogenannten drei parteien gesprächen
mit den libanesischen und israelischen
streitkräfte wir dürfen ja nicht
vergessen dass er kriegszustand zwischen
israel und dem libanon offiziell noch
nicht beendet ist weiterhin erkennen
sich beide staaten nicht an land und
seegrenzen sind die stress gelegt aber
bald akzeptieren und schützen den
wertvollen uni viel streit stiftungs
mechanismus nur unter dem dach der
vereinten nationen tauschen sie sich
direkt aus also beide libanon und israel
haben großes interesse an der präsenz
der vereinten nationen und der deutsche
beteiligung zweitens geht es aber auch
um die unterbindung von waffenschmuggel
aus dem von den mehr heraus das hilft
das hilft dabei die ausrüstung von
gruppen wie zum beispiel dollar zu
verhindern die die stabilität des
libanon und die sicherheit israels
bedrohen dieser beitrag aus sie gegen
den waffenschmuggel und gegen den
waffenschmuggel in den libanon hat zwei
komponenten einmal sichert die maritime
ohne viel komponente die seeseite ab es
werden nur noch vereinzelt
waffenschmuggel über see registriert und
es zeigt nicht die wirksamkeit dieses
einsatzes und wir leisten einen beitrag
dazu dass die libanesische marine
langfristig die grenzsicherung auf see
selbst übernehmen kann drittens die
bundesregierung verfolgt indem wir nun
einen versetzen einen vernetzten ansatz
von außen sicherheits und
entwicklungspolitischen instrumenten
vereint allein 700 1 5 millionen
flüchtlinge aus syrien aufgenommen und
angesichts der sechs millionen einwohner
des libanon ist das eine beachtenswerte
und enorme leistung die unseren respekt
verdient
meine damen und herren
steht man da das hier im hause zur
zustimmung vorliegt müssen wir abwägen
zwischen gefahren und verantwortung die
beratung zu dem uni viel mandat beginnen
jetzt wir die spd-fraktion sind der
festen überzeugung dass es das richtige
und vernünftige dass die richtige und
vernünftige entscheidung ist dieses ohne
uno-mandat diese un-mission weiterhin zu
unterstützen
und bis zum 30 juni 23 zu verlängern und
ich hoffe dass dieses hohe haus sich mit
großer mehrheit zu unserer
internationalen verantwortung bekennt
und
lieber herr und
kollegen anforderungen sie bitte zum
schluss sie ihre fraktion wohl nicht hat
danke
ich komme das letzte mal zurück zum
tagesordnungspunkt
30 und gebe ihnen das von ihnen
schriftführerinnen und schriftführern
ermittelte ergebnis der namentlichen
abstimmung bekannt
abgegebene stimmen karten
636 mit ja haben
468 abgeordnete gestimmt mit nein
stimmten 166 und es gab zwei
enthaltungen
die beschlussempfehlung ist angenommen
nun kommen wir wieder zurück zur debatte
zum tages- und so das war hier noch
einmal die abstimmung
zu einem antrag von der unionsfraktion
der aber hier abgelehnt wurde man stimmt
hier nicht über den antrag an sich ab
sondern über eine beschlussempfehlung
des ausschusses und wie gesagt dieser
antrag wurde jetzt abgelehnte ging es
noch einmal um die wohn förderung jetzt
geht's hier weiter in der debatte um den
und wir als bundeswehr aber haben
gemeinsam mit den beteiligten nationen
vor ort sind auf ausdrücklichen wunsch
der israelis und auf ausdrücklichen
wunsch des libanons damit vor ort die
einhaltung des waffenstillstands
abkommens überwacht wird das klappt im
wesentlichen sehr gut auch in der
internationalen zusammenarbeit und
deswegen ist das mandat auch unverändert
sinnvoll und notwendig und anders als
der kollege wundrak für die fdp-fraktion
hier gesagt hat muss ich sagen ich halte
das auch für eine kernaufgabe der
bundeswehr der deutschen marine und auch
unseres parlaments es geht eben nicht
nur darum die landes- und
bündnisverteidigung punkt auf dem
eigenen hoheitsgebiet die dfds immer
wieder behauptet zu stärken sondern es
geht darum dass wir auch international
unsere verantwortung dort wahrnehmen wo
krieg herrscht die menschen sterben wo
folter und unterdrückung herrscht und wo
wir einen stabilitätsbeitrag leisten
können dass die bundeswehr in unserem
auftrag und darauf sind wir stolz meinte
er
anders als die fdp behauptet hat ist der
auftrag auch nicht beendet
wie ich erlebe
rechtsextreme parteien seit beginn
meiner politischen tätigkeit mit ganz
unterschiedlichen namen und köpfen
aber ich würde auch nie behaupten dass
wir mit der bekämpfung des
rechtsextremismus in deutschland fertig
sind nur weil die fdp weise wie aus den
landtagen verschwindet fertig ist eine
aufgabe erst dann den frieden und
stabilität herrscht wenn vor ort
sichergestellt ist dass die aufgaben der
küstenwache in zukunft durch den libanon
selbst wahrgenommen werden kann wenn
stabilität herrscht vor ort dann ist das
mandat und die aufgabe erfüllt aber
nicht wenn die ard dass hier im
parlament behauptet man
der auftrag muss auch deswegen
weitergehen weil nach aussage des ja
mittlerweile mit der militärischen
führung beauftragten admirals die
aufgaben noch nicht erfüllt ist die
libanesen sind noch nicht in der lage
die aufgaben des küstenschutzes
eigenständig wahrzunehmen das liegt
teilweise an den materiellen fehlenden
fähigkeiten der generalinspekteur der
bundeswehr hat ja unlängst auch die
verstärkung der örtlichen küstenwache
noch mal um moderne patrouillenboote
verlangt darüber werden wir hoffentlich
im rahmen der tüchtiges initiative auch
miteinander reden aber auch die
ausbildung hat noch nicht den stand
erreicht dass die aufgabenwahrnehmung
allein und durch die libanesen selbst
vorgenommen werden könnte meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren wir werden
deswegen vor ort weiter gebraucht um
diesen einsatz fortzusetzen ich bin sehr
froh dass die parlamentarische mitte
dieses hauses in den letzten jahren
diese mission immer unterstützt hat und
zwar unabhängig von der jeweiligen rolle
in der regierung oder der opposition
und auch nicht unabhängig von der lage
wenn sie die jeweiligen
aufträge lesen dann werden sie schon
sehen dass sich die lage fortschreibung
geändert hat dass wir große fortschritte
vor ort gemacht hätten haben die hier
nie gemacht hätten wenn wir ihren
politischen ideologien gefolgt und den
einsatz abgebrochen hätten meine sehr
verehrten
die argumentationen ändern sich ja warum
der einsatz aus den beiden blöcken links
und rechts im extrem dieses parlaments
abgebrochen werden soll die wahrheit ist
doch als linke sind sie gegen jeden
auslandseinsatz der bundeswehr sie
wollen die nato abschaffen sie waren ein
neues militärbündnis und
sicherheitsbündnis mit russland gründen
denn das noch aktuell ist was in ihrem
wahlprogramm steht hat es sich
vielleicht ja auch ein bisschen überholt
sie wollen eigentlich gar keine
bundeswehr und keine einsätze dann
erfinden sie doch nicht hier immer
wieder
und warum sie gegen die einsätze sind
sie sind gegen diese einsätze weil sie
gegen die bundeswehr sind meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren und dann muss
man das hier im parlament
bei der afg verhält es sich ein bisschen
anders sie sind auch gegen die einsätze
aus unterschiedlichen gründen ich habe
mir die letzten parlamentsdebatten ganz
bewusst in vorbereitung noch die heutige
debatte nummer angeschaut je nach redner
sind sie mal aus ganz unterschiedlichen
gründen dagegen ich will nur deswegen
auch noch mal sagen wenn sie sagen es
seien keine waffen und drogen gefunden
worden auf dem die auf dem seeweg in den
libanon gelangt sein dann haben sie
recht aber das ist doch der erfolg der
mission nichts zu finden ist die aufgabe
dieser dieser mission eben die
sicherheit so zu gewährleisten und die
kontrolldichte dass am ende keine waffen
und drogen geschmuggelt werden können
ich will meine sehr verehrten damen und
herren schließen mit einem bericht den
der korvettenkapitän pascal stört
gegeben hat nach der rückkehr der
korvette braunschweig er hat gesagt
berücksichtigt man die zweiwöchige
quarantäne vor einsatzbeginn waren 160
tage unterwegs und konnten uns während
des einsatzes nur auf unser weniger als
90 meter großen korvette aufhalten ich
finde unsere soldatinnen und soldaten
leisten vor ort gewaltiges ich will mir
gar nicht vorstellen
frau präsidentin kommen zum schluss ich
will mir gar nicht vorstellen wenn man
die afg fraktion die ungefähr die größe
dieser truppeneinheit hätte 160 tage
lang allein auf 1 90 meter langes schiff
sperren würde was dabei raus kenne auf
jeden fall kein erfolgreicher einsatz
[Applaus]
für die fraktion bündnis 90 die grünen
hat nun die kollegin anja gadow das
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte damen und herren liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen im august 2020
um 18 uhr und 8 wurde das leben in
beirut erschüttert wir alle haben die
schrecklichen bilder der explosion und
bei guter hafen noch vor augen 207
menschen wurden getötet mehr als 6500
verletzt mehr als 300.000 menschen
mussten ihre häuser verlassen
eine stadt in schutt und asche eine
katastrophe die hätte verhindert werden
können diese katastrophe steht auf so
tragische weise sind möglich für die
korruption und misswirtschaft der
politischen eliten bis heute ist keiner
der verantwortlichen politiker zur
rechenschaft gezogen worden der skandal
des skandals in einem land bei dem nicht
nur ich mich immer wieder frage und es
endgültig zusammen wie lange schaffen
sie es noch doch die männer und frauen
lieber man sie sind stark gestatten sie
mir ein schicksal hier in die pläne
plenarsaal zu tragen da stellvertretend
für die jungen engagierten liebe leserin
lieber leser steht
radfahrers war feuerwehrfrau sie alte
mit ihrem team zum butter hafen als die
erste rauchwolke aufstieg sie wollte
einen brand im lagerhaus mission nur
kurz nachdem sie eintraf fand die
eigentliche explosion stadt sagte fur
das war sofort tot und sie war die
einzige frau im team
sehr geehrte damen und herren sachen
wollte eine bessere zukunft sie steht
sinnbildlich so viele akteurinnen und
akteure in der libanesischen
zivilgesellschaft die mutig sein müssen
um die politische zukunft ihres landes
zu gestalten denn irland schenkt ihnen
nichts es liegt am boden die ergebnisse
der parlamentswahl vom vergangenen
sonntag sind dann auch der versuch der
politischen elite einen denkzettel zu
verpassen wenigstens meine damen und
herren welche rolle spielt juni nun
außenpolitisch für die gesamtregion
müssen wir festhalten
das friedensabkommen zwischen dem
libanon und israel ist nach wie vor
nicht beschlossen fortschritte bei der
entwaffnung
gewaltbereite gruppierung vornehmlich
der im süden präsenten fußballer bleiben
aus in diesen fragilen
sicherheitspolitische umfeld bleibt die
zustimmung zum mandat ein wesentliches
stabilisierendes element juni will ist
aktuell der einzige verbindungs und
koordinations mechanismus zwischen
israel und dem libanon und juni für wie
sowohl von israel als auch vom libanon
gewünscht und so wird es hoffentlich
helfen die differenzen und spannungen
zwischen israel und dem libanon durch
dialog und kooperation zu reduzieren
daher empfehle ich meine zustimmung
[Applaus]